la famille d'adèle ghoul à 35 ans tuée
de onze balles le 6 mai devant un fast
food de plaisir a organisé vendredi soir
un rassemblement devant le commissariat
de trappes pour réclamer le droit de
récupérer son corps et de l'enterrer
dignement
une cinquantaine de personnes ont
répondu à cet appel la mère de la
victime son frère sa soeur était présent
très douloureux c'est pour nous c'est
une double peine en fait voilà on a le
voilà on à l'assassinât de mon frère est
le fait des complices parlent qui paraît
son camp et ne pas pouvoir voilà le
l'enterrer dignement et voilà de
d'essayer d'aller de l'avant et de dates
entre le juge n'a pas encore accordé le
permis d'inhumer
il peut décider de le faire après huit
jours voire plus cela suscite
l'incompréhension et la douleur de la
famille
un tueur toujours recherché et dangereux
on a peur on a peur pour voilà moi j'ai
peur pour les membres de ma famille on
reste cloîtré chez nous il a menacé au
passé plusieurs membres de ma famille en
l'occurrence ma soeur ses proches ne
veulent pas attendre l'interpellation du
suspect avant de pouvoir enterrer adel
en tunisie
l'homme recherché est également suspecté
d'avoir blessé deux autres personnes
attrapent ce lundi soir une nouvelle
manifestation a lieu devant la mairie de
trappes
la réponse du juge se fait toujours
attendre